[Musique]
avec les doigts bonjour ça va bien j'ai
très bien vous qui ont aussi su bien oui
je suis dans une forme dangereuse on
parle parce que c'est bientôt la fête
nationale le 24 janvier on parle de jean
pierre ferland justement il a fait un
beau cadeau 75 oui de l'année la chanson
un peu plus haut oui mais c'était pas
moi qui devais la chance non c'est
uniqlo qu'est ce que ce monsieur m'a
joué j'ai peur que ce soit votre chance
et la seconde pour gagner 10 fait gentil
et modifie la motion sérieusement je
vous jure sur la tête de dieu je devais
pas chanter un peu plus
[Musique]
j'avais beaucoup beaucoup d'émotion ce
journal parce que je voulais finir le
spectacle à jean pierre jeunet de faire
un énorme succès avec mon amour chute
mais 13 puis je voulais chanter un peu
plus haut que mon amour peu près sûr je
me disais tout le monde vous bénéficiez
pas ce que je vais lancer un grain clic
une joie teintée donc à toute tentation
sim était comme g6 le sait la foule
serait vont chanter avec nous ou en
projet
m
à la fin de votre tour de chance de me
dit c'est beau la machine québécois pure
laine pure sont fiers des québécois
suffire de julien je suis fier du
parcours que j'ai fait j'ai fait un
énorme parcours je viens de très loin
quand vous allez rire ma vie vous allez
comprendre il avait remporté le prix
artisan csu bout et l'avocat qui
soulignait que vous a remis le le
mouvement des québécoises et des
québécois qu'est ce que ça signifie pour
voudra portable comme ça c'est très
gratifiant c'est juste que je me
rappelle toujours mon arc fait longtemps
que je suis de l'année prochaine ça va
faire soit ce matin mais c'est c'est
toujours avec un grand plaisir
un grand bonheur dans mes journées
dépressive j'allume la lumière je me dis
j'ai fait quelque chose qu'avec moi
[Musique]
vous êtes convaincus que votre voix est
un don de dieu à chérir beau dessous je
pense que sur tout même des maîtres de
la façon dont je suis né je ne vais pas
net
mon père a fait un goitre que les
avancées y être opéré les médecins lyon
peut il en musique un dépôt d'armes est
restée la même et aller à la chapelle de
l'hôpital que la didone redonne la
vérité un bonhomme je te redonne un
troisième enfant
c'est enfin l'heure de nuit un don donc
mon père faisait guan card il qu'à 12
verset c'est comme un miracle
donc je je pense que déjà là j'avais une
mission g pour finir si je me prête vie
je me sens beaucoup sur ce que j'ai à
faire
j'ai besoin
[Musique]
et j'ai beau le chercher
tous les jours toutes les nuits jamais
compris des joueurs suisses ont bouché
publie pas l'air deux loustics je me
lève puis me chante un pur jégou des les
fansites de reçus vous avez 72 ans que
notre santé 12 mai mais ouais de
toujours le goût de chanter comme ça en
avoir la peau ma préparation mais je
peux que regretter mais me championne
chez nous ils sont tannés de mou et je
leur rends tout petit jeu les fatigues
le mans nexo l'assumons en janvier
prochain et roger pensais jamais son dlc
bois jamais je voudrais vous plaît mais
jamais je veux des crises a fait nommer
ce monsieur mais qu'est ce que vous
voulez faire le plus dur là-bas ma
préparation je pense que je veux vous
dire la maison j'ai entre nous c'est sûr
pour aider un peu
l'humanité parce qu'ils sont beaucoup de
monde dix autres saucisses yeux elle va
mourir j'aimerais voir c'est le temps de
faire ce sujet demandé laisse bouffer
mon abonnement tracé pour prétendre au
jeu vraiment ouvrir une maison jouer les
autres merci mais non merci
[Musique]